so if you feel you're not getting what
you want and you're a storyteller
maybe you're the one that sees something
that needs a resurface
that you like or you see something
that's not there ever and never been
there
and you want to destroy the current
movement you want to put it into the
passe
and this is your critique on it then you
should
has hollywood run out of ideas peter no
because you can't run out of human
experiences and everybody
who's ever born looks at the world in a
different way
why do we hear that so much though we
see it in our comments we
we hear it all the time that it seems
we've run out of ideas we're only
repeating the same
story or ip over and over again
it depends where you look i mean i'm
sure that
it's also a taste thing because some
movies get made more
some kind of character or genre
and there's an audience for that but
if we're adventurous just go on
letterbox
like letterbox is like the coolest
website around or app and it just has
so much exploration for movies and
during the pandemic i created a crime
film club where i would curate movies
to my friends and some of them were you
know in asia
and all around the world and we before
we'd hop on a
zoom call we'd watch one of these movies
that i picked
and i used letterbox to find them
and every title i tried to
pick something that was obscure
and nobody's seen in the group because
there are some cinephiles they're pretty
hardcore
so then it became like a fun challenge
can i get something that they haven't
seen
and i was successful i i found multiple
movies that like the most hardcore crime
film fans
didn't ever hear of and we had
incredible time talking about them so
i think the question is are the movies
that you feel
are derivative maybe it's the type of
projects you just don't want to watch
that's fine what about you know
the onus is on you because like there's
international cinema
there's incredible storytellers on
youtube there's
so many you know really interesting
points of view or there's podcasts that
have
you know started being created in the
audio drama space with stories
from you know creators that
we haven't been introduced to yet but
now they're here in a new medium
so i think that lying about there isn't
enough
x or whatever i think that
anybody is commenting on that they have
a point
to some degree because maybe they just
don't like what's popular
but then they also have the
responsibility to seek out what they
find interesting
well taking it with music since i know
you're you're a
music aficionado so a lot of people say
oh well there's no good music it made
after the 2000s or whatever
would you say that they just haven't
looked hard enough they haven't found
some indie bands or different artists
that they're they're still in this
mindset of what was fed to us through
radio
back in the day which has kind of gone
away
i mean maybe there's a band that they
like
and they broke up or there was a
movement
and that isn't the
the dominant one you know the artists
are not pushing in that
space you know pushing that space or
it's not getting a lot of press
i mean i can't say don't feel bad about
the lack of the type of
movies or music or you know writing
that you've seen and if in it you see
like there's just a desert
you know and there's not an abundance of
options i mean you should mourn that if
that's the nostalgic quality i mean if
you miss a certain
type of thing i get that i can only
speak to myself
like i can't say this is what the
industry is doing or not doing
i could say that when i was looking for
movies
to entertain very cynical friends of
mine who've seen everything
and i found things that were very
inspiring that's from my own
you know experience but if there is
specific
types of storytellers or stories that
you don't see
that's a valid concern i don't want to
deny that i can only
talk about within my own you know
range of experiences and you know
what i've seen but then at the same time
if you don't see what what's out there
and you
it's kind of inspiration maybe for you
as an artist because now there's more
fuel
to get you
really plugged into a certain type of
thing that
that's missing in some ways i think art
is kind of like criticism
if you make a movie that is a crime film
that is directly uh
diametrically like opposed to what's out
there like if it's
all about like 80s action films and then
another
style comes out that's different or
a horror genre starts and it's
all meta and that's the thing
everything's things about meta is that
there's these different movements
and sometimes a new movement upends an
old one
so if you feel you're not getting what
you want and you're a storyteller
maybe you're the one that sees something
that needs to resurface
that you like or you see something
that's not there ever and never been
there
and you want to destroy the current
movement you want to put it into the
passe
and this is your critique on it then you
should
you should destroy you should in a way
it's like you're kind of
becoming the next voice
that's going to resonate and you might
mean that you are
in confrontation with the current
you know fancy you know filmmaker or
author or painter
and you're a necessary part of this
you know the waves that will happen you
know in our culture and
then you should bring upon change you
should fight to bring upon change but
you don't like what's out there
and if you're not a creator you're a
critic you could attack what's out there
you know or if you're just a commentator
you could comment on this youtube video
and that's still a critique of something
i mean
that's totally fine i don't i don't
think
it's all or one thing i think it's a
confluence of different
perspectives it brings to mind this
quote um we don't see things
as they are we see things as we are
exactly so then
when we complain that there's no more
good movies anymore there's no good
music anymore we can't
it's all been done before it's really
more on us
it's what it's the filter that we're
seeing it through and that
maybe that means that we need to tell
those stories well i don't think
people should be able to complain about
what's out there i think it's fine i'm
just saying
that in some way
if you really don't like a certain way
a genre is being explored by the current
you know fancy people in the space who
are getting all the attention
you might come out of left field
and completely like ruckshop on it like
there could be a
there could be a musician from
soundcloud that says i hate
what these djs are doing now and
electronic music they don't know what's
going on
and because of the the platforms
are so much about amplifying
anything that gets traction you might
just in your
parents basement make a song that gets
attention
and now you're challenging what's out
there or you make a film for no budget
it plays the festivals and then suddenly
people go oh it's not about
the thing that you don't like or if
you're like i said if you're not a
filmmaker
you're just a writer you just comment on
every article you're still there you're
still
present you're still pushing against
something it's okay to not
be a fan of what's out there you know i
think it's ridiculous if someone's like
just smile and consume everything
you don't have to you could you could
just
be annoyed that whatever you're really
into is not being like
embraced but then you also
have the abilities to be a thorn in the
side of what's there
or potentially be a death sentence to
that
movement that you don't like and maybe
not a distance in the sense that it
never could get reborn
but lily could put on hold stop it and
then challenge it with your own voice
just be like a mindless consumer you
think that's what they want from us
i don't think anybody wants to be a
miles consumer and i think that like
the idea that there's a hollywood movie
and it's just you know doesn't take
thinking
to make a movie nobody who's making
movies mindless
it's incredibly challenging you know
task
to do that and there's so many people
involved
in the process that are brilliant so i
don't think a movie is just
mindless and i do think that a movie's
goal is to have some type of reaction
you know it's not they don't want an
apathetic
audience that doesn't feel anything
they're they're wanting to like
create an experience that's memorable or
at least not memorable
it makes you forget the challenges of
your life so
you know i don't think that is idea that
you just pour
content down somebody's mouth
and that's uh and that's what it what
the system is it doesn't work that way
it's it's a there's al it's basically
there's all sorts of stories
that are being told and some of them
being pushed
to front and center some of them are
more in the background
and as time goes they shift
uh based on the what's popular or what's
you know the new cool you know the new
cool voices
the new cool distributor you know what's
824 doing it just
keeps shifting you know but
it's your job to decide
where you're participating in it if
you're commenting on it
and if you don't want to do anything
else you just think that it's bad it's
fine too
like there's no there's no
responsibility for any individual
regarding what level of in you know
proximity they have
to this culture as a creator
or a commentator excellent point
so we have free will of course to extend
and the algorithm doesn't follow us and
i mean
it depends on how you um consume content
or movies or comic books or
i mean like there's a spectrum of ex
ways that you interact with media
is it physical is it you're super
nostalgic and you get dvds and vhs
are you getting them off netflix are you
getting them off criterion
i just don't think there's like a one
size fits all
for anybody and there isn't like just
some psychographics that defines a giant
chunk where everyone's like
all you do is watch these videos be
because that's not true i mean
i listen to certain types of podcasts
watch sharing con's movies read certain
kinds of journalism like
i'm a very specific in that way and
there's other people that will be all
about watching video games on youtube
or somebody's all about food i think
that like
there's this idea that like there's the
death of what we
of what we love or there's nothing here
i do think that there's
ways that journalists sometimes will
create
an absolute like they'll say it's like
so i think they're creating the
and sometimes not all of them obviously
but some of them
have like a frame that's convenient
because it invokes conversation
so it's like how do i how do i say
something that's bombastic
that gets you talking i mean i know for
a little while uh
years ago they were saying horror movies
are dead that was like an article
there was a few bombs or whatever horror
movies are dead
and then i was like how's that true when
the world at times is horrific
when the human experience could just be
terrifying and confusing
how could hormone movies be dead yet we
need an outlet
to comment on
this complex nature of our mortality so
there's no way
but at the same time the journalists
maybe just want people to talk about
we're sick of schlocky horror movies and
maybe that's the protest that's
the writing that's fine but i just think
that these type of frames
on the grand scheme as much as they're
conversation starters
if you take them too seriously they're
also limiting
you